لاغنى رجل في العالم ولمالك تويتر والرئيس
التنفيذي لتسلاين ملياردير ايلون ماسك
اصيب من اخباري تفاعلكم اليوم فماسك من
بدايه امتلاكه لمنصه تويتر اجرى الكثير من
التغييرات فيها بدءا من تسريح الموظفين
مرورا برسوم التوثيق وانتهاء بسياسات
جديده لتويتر احدث ما اعلن عنه ماسك هو
حذف الحسابات غير النشطه على تويتر فكتب
في تغريده ان تويتر سيقوم بحذف كل
الحسابات التي لم تسجل دخولا الى تويتر
وغير النشطه منذ سنوات حيث تنص السياسه
الجديده لتويتر على ضروره ان يقوم صاحب
الحساب بتسجيل الدخول كل ثلاثين يوما على
الاقل للحفاظ على حسابه وهذه العمليه في
حال بدات ستكون اكبر عمليه حذف للحسابات
في منصات تويتر حيث قال ماسك الكثير من
مستخدمي تويتر سيلاحظون انخفاضا في عدد
المتابعين في حساباتهم وهذه النقطه تخوف
منها الكثير من مستخدمي تويتر وفي رده على
احد المنتقدين القرار والذي اكد ان هناك
الكثير من الحسابات القديمه تحوي تغريدات
تاريخيه يحبها الناس ويرجعون اليها كل
فتره قلماسك ان تلك الحسابات سيتم ارشفتها
وليس حتفها وهنا لابد ان نشيرنا هذه
العمليه جزء من عمليه توثيق الحسابات
والتاكد منها والحد من الحسابات الوهميه
التي تعاني منها منصات تويتر وكل
الاجراءات التي يقوم بها ماسك يسعى من
خلالها لرفع ايرادات تويتر وتحسين الوضع
الحالي للمنصه ومنها اعلان دعمه لمنشئي
المحتوى على تويتر فنشرت تغريده تنقل فيها
الى تويتر يدعم منشئي المحتوى ولن يحصل
على ارباح من ايراداتهم في العام الاول من
اشتراكهم في تويتر وبعدها سياخذ تويتر
عشره في المئه فقط من الارباح
عبر زوم ينضم الينا من دبي نسل مرعي
للمتخصص في الشؤون المعلوماتيه والتقنيه
اهلا بك انس معنا في تفاعلكم وفي العربيه
يعني احدث التغييرات والسياسات الجديده
لماسك على تويتر هي حذف الحسابات غير
النشطه منذ سنوات كيف تقراون هذا القرار
اولا
مساء لجميع المشاهدين بالضبط مثل ما
تفضلتي هو في الرد على اجابته لاحدى
المنتقدين المعروفين او احدى كبار
الشخصيات على تويتر قال بانه سوف يتم
ارشفتها ولو نظرنا لكلمه ارشفتها كان ممكن
ما تكون بالضروره تعني هذه الحسابات وعلى
سيره حذف الحسابات بنعرف انه كانت مشكله
كبيره في
شراء صفقه تويتر وكان لهن ماسك واحد من
اهم يعني هو
الوحده من اهم مشاكله اللي هي الحسابات
اللي الوهميه اللي بتنشئها البوت فهو بهاي
الطريقه عم بحاول يمشي مع التيار ويمشي
فقط حتى نفهم من الناحيه التقنيه ما الفرق
بين ارشفتها وحذف وكيف يمكن لمستخدمي
تويتر ان يصلوا الحسابات المؤرشفه
[موسيقى]
سوف يتم ارشفتها ارشفتها ممكن يضلل
الاكاونت يبقى على تويتر لكن ما في هناك
اي اكتيفي ممكن اتوقع انهم ينشؤوا خاصيه
جديده كما فعلت فيسبوك من قبل بحيث في حال
لولا سمح الله توفى الشخص انه شخص اخر
يستلم الحساب او هذا الحساب يبقى كما هو
يعني الجميع قادر على الاطلاع عليه
المستقبل سيحمل يعني بعض الاهداف ماسك
الحقيقيه من وراء هذا القرار يعني الماسك
يقول انه الهدف من العمليه هو توثيق
الحسابات التاكد منها والتخلص من الحسابات
الوهميه التي اتعبت تويتر لكن في المقابل
المختصين يرون انه السياسه ماسك الجديده
الدفعه مقابل التوثيق ادت الى زياده كبيره
في الحسابات الوهميه في تويتر كيف يمكن
فهم هذا التناقض
من وجهه نظري متناقض توثيق الحسابات لا
يعني بالضبط التوثيق المعروف اللي هو
العلامه الزرقاء لربما يقصد
ماسكها يعني وجه نظر شخصيه هي التاكد وقال
اتبع كمال لو دخلنا على تغريداته
واتباعنا في الرد كان يقول لازم نفضي
المساحه للحسابات القديمه شو يعني مثلا
فلان عنده حساب او باسمه بس مو قادر ياخذه
لانه شخص ما مقفل هذا الاكونت او اخذ
الاسم وحجزه هذا الموضوع بتعرفي يعني مسبب
مشاكل لكثير مؤسسات حكوميه ومؤسسات رسميه
هو اشخاص اصحاب راي وبالتالي هذا الشيء
ضروري يعني انا انا من وجهه نظري هي خطوه
ضروريه جدا على جميع الاتجاهات ان شاء
الله يعني
القرار النهائي يكون التويتر ولا ماسك فيه
صالح المستخدمين سواء الاحياء منهم ام او
الاموال على الصعيدين ما رايك في من ينتقد
هذه السياسات الجديده لماسكو يقول انه
الهدف منها هي جن الايرادات فقط وتحسين
وضع تويتر خصوصا انه بعض العلامات
التجاريه وبعض الاشخاص ابدوا استعدادهم
لدفع الاف الدولارات من اجل شراء حسابات
لاشخاص او حسابات قديمه
هلا قضيه التوثيق قضيه مهمه جدا
يعني اي قرار بيتخذه ماسك او غيره راح
يكون في له معارضين ومؤيدين قضيه انه انا
اكون معارض او مؤيد تعكس مصالح الشخصيه ما
قد يكون مع مصالح الشخصيه قد يخالف
الاخرين لكن انا ارى فينا خطوه جيده لانه
كان معيار التوثيق نوعا ما في نوع من
الضبابيه الان اصبح واضح جدا الان اصبحنا
نعرف انه هذا الحساب فعلا هو حساب رئيسي
للمؤسسه الفلانيه او للوزير الفلاني او
للرئيس الفلاني صار في نوع من
الشفافيه في هذا الموضوع لا ارى
الجهه الثانيه لكن هناك الكثير من الاشخاص
العاديين الذين فقدوا موضوع التوثيق صار
فيقول انا ليش لادفع فلوس ما انا كنت
متوثق من الاصل هون صار اللغات الكبير
خلينا نقول الحرب الكلاميه بين اللي كان
حساب متوثق وبين اللي توثق جديد وما كانت
عنده هاي الفرصه من قبل
الاشخاص يشتكون بانه هناك اشخاص اخرين
اشتروا مقابل اسمائهم شكرا من زوم عبر زوم
من دبي انس المراعي متخصص في الشؤون
المعلوماتيه والتقنيه شكرا جزيلا لك انس
[موسيقى]